hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to be
talking about the structure of the
nucleus so focusing on those things that
are inside the nucleus before we launch
into that i want to make sure you know
about something new that i'm doing and
that is providing board notes so you can
check for a link in the description
below there will be a link to a drive
folder where you can get a pdf of the
final board so the final board with all
of the blanks filled in
for all of my recent videos you can get
them for free just check out that link
in the description
also make sure that you subscribe for
more biology study videos now let's go
ahead and get started
so in the nucleus we're focusing on
things like the nuclear lamina the
nuclear matrix the nucleoplasm here i
have drawn a diagram of the nucleus of
course this is situated within the the
larger cell so outside of here there's
cytoplasm and other organelles of the
cell but we're focusing on the nucleus
i have numbered various parts of the
nuclear structure and i'll be referring
to them as we go through the notes so
first let's kind of take a look at
what's on the outside of the nucleus um
making up the nuclear boundary and that
is this membrane system so you've got an
outer membrane an inner membrane
a space in the middle called the
perinuclear space and it's studied with
nuclear pores so let's put that into
context here the nuclear envelope
that is
another sometimes more formal name for
the nuclear membrane the nuclear
envelope it separates the nucleoplasm
that's in here from the cytoplasm that
is outside the nucleus it consists of
two membranes as i said the outer one in
the inner one
two membranes punctured by thousands of
nuclear pores
and those are drawn in red so thousands
of these pores around this big sort of
spherical nucleus
these pores
are made of large
hollow
protein complexes
so these pores right here they're made
of protein they're hollow that allows
things to go from the cytoplasm into the
nucleus and from inside the nucleus back
out into the cytoplasm so those pores do
span both membranes and have like a lot
of regulatory function also i mentioned
in between the outer membrane and the
inner membrane there is like a small
kind of
compartment
called the peri-nuclear space
okay
um i also want to point out a few more
things before we move on and that is
that this outer membrane is continuous
with the endoplasmic reticulum which i'm
abbreviating as er so i've drawn that a
little bit here that outer membrane is
continuous meaning connected to
the membrane
system that makes up the endoplasmic
reticulum so that's another way in which
things can kind of go from
the nucleus into the endoplasmic
reticulum
and then also these nuclear pores i
really already said this but i want to
make sure that i write it down for you
and that is that they regulate entry
into
an exit
out of the nucleus
so now we'll go on to five through eight
five through eight here we've got the
nucleoplasm the nuclear lamina the
nuclear matrix and then up here the
nuclear matrix proteins so let's talk
about those now the nucleoplasm contains
the nuclear
lamina
these are composed of lamin
proteins now laming proteins are a type
of intermediate filament i do have
another
video on the cytoskeleton where i talk
about microtubules
microfilaments and intermediate
filaments and so if you want to learn
more about those you can check out that
video
the nuclear lamina is composed of lamin
proteins that they support the inner
membrane they anchor
the pore complexes they have a few other
things that they do too in addition to
that mechanical support
and by mechanical support i'm talking
about this right here supporting the
inner membrane anchoring those nuclear
pore complexes
they also
and this nuclear lamina is these kinds
of green
crisscross fibers that go around
supporting that inner membrane they also
help to regulate a few very very
important processes for the cell they
help to regulate cell division
remember
that
during cell division during mitosis
you've got the the chromatinic condenses
and the chromosomes they have to be
separated the
nucleus the nuclear envelope has to
dissolve for that to happen and then
reform later and the nuclear lamina
helps with that process
and the nuclear lamina also regulates uh
you know dna replication as well so it's
not just a supportive function it's also
got these regulatory functions so very
important is the nuclear lamina
uh then the nucleoplasm also contains
the nuclear
matrix
remember that the nuclear matrix
is basically in here and it's it is
similar in function
to
the
um
to the cytosol
so the same way that in the cell you've
got the cytosol
and sort of um the cytoplasm all of the
cytoskeleton that's there
the nuclear matrix acts in a sort of
similar fashion i will say that it's a
lot more dynamic than the cytoplasm
um and there's still a lot of questions
about kind of how exactly it works
um
but yeah so the nuclear matrix is in
there the nucleoplasm
is also known as
the
nucleosol okay so the nucleoplasm is in
there um
and that's that is sort of made up of
the nuclear matrix and the nuclear
matrix proteins
uh now let's go on to nine through ten
this is kind of bringing us to the end
of our of our discussion on the nuclear
structure and here we're talking about
the dna and the nucleolus or nucleolus
it's got two pronunciations there so the
dna in the nucleus
exists in two different forms
so the dna can be loose with
transcription activity
this is called
euchromatin
or it can be
condensed and inactive so not currently
supporting transcription and that is
called
heterochromatin
so just as a reminder when we're talking
about transcription activity
remember
that this involves the central dogma so
we've got
dna
is used as a template
to make rna
and the particular type of rna that's
used as a template to make protein
that's the messenger rna
and so this right here is the central
dogma i have another video on the
central dogma if you want to check that
out but it's just the idea
that
information in the cell flows from dna
through rna to protein and the two
processes that link this are
transcription that's the making of the
rna from the dna template and
translation the making of the protein
from the rna template and so this right
here i'm going to kind of circle this
arrow
that is where transcription is taking
place so when we say loose dna it's
loose it's open
it's available for
uh for the polymerase the rna
polymerases to get in there and to
transcribe the dna to make that
transcript that can then be used to make
the protein of course i'll also add that
the transcripts that are made during
transcription and the nucleus they've
got to get out into the cytoplasm to
find a ribosome
to
be translated and how do they get out of
the nucleus through the nuclear pore
complexes
okay and then the other thing i want to
point out within our nucleus is this
right here in the nucleus there's like a
dark staining region that you can see
it's like a darker
kind of region within the nucleus and
that is the nucleolus or the nucleolus
again you've got those two
pronunciations but that is the site of
rrna ribosomal rna synthesis and
ribosome assembly so that's the
nucleolus
um
and so that brings us to the end of our
discussion on the structure of the
nucleus make sure you grab the board
notes from the link below make sure you
hit subscribe
and i hope to see you
next time for more biology study videos
thank you for watching biology professor
bye